تساءلت صحيفه فاينانشال تايمز ان كانت
اسرائيل تستطيع تحقيق اهداف حربها في غزه
ورات ان الصراع في قطاع غزه يتحول الى حرب
استنزاف بينما تعاني اسرائيل لتحقيق
اهدافها المعلنه ونقلت الصحيفه عن مصدر
مطلع على خطط الحرب الاسرائيليه ان حماس
ما زالت تحتفظ بالقدره على اطلاق الصواريخ
خصوصا من المناطق التي لم تصلها القوات
البريه الاسرائيليه بعد وربما تختار
الحفاظ على
ترسانتها صمت نتنياهو يمهد الطريق امام
التطهير العرقي الاسرائيلي للفلسطينيين في
غزه هكذا رات افتتاحيه صحيفتها ارتس مشيره
الى اجتماع من وصفتهم بالاعضاء الاقوياء
في الائتلاف الحاكم لتقديم الهدف الجديد
للحرب على غزه والاحتفال به بالرقص وتابعت
الافتتاحيه ان صمت نتنياهو على ما وقع في
مؤتمر العوده للاستيطان في قطاع غزه
مثل صمت شخصيات بارزه اخرى في الليكود
يعبر عن علاقات القوه السياسيه في
الائتلاف وفي المجلس الوزاري المصغر حيث
تقلص دور رئيس الوزراء ليصبح ضابط الدعايه
لبن كفير و سموتريتش
[موسيقى]
نقلت صحيفه التليغراف عن الكولونيل افي
بانوف وهو مسؤول طبي كبير بالجيش
الاسرائيلي قوله ان عدد الضحايا الذين
سقطوا في الاشهر الاربعه الماضيه اكبر مما
شهدته اسرائيل في العقود الاربعه الماضيه
واضاف ان الجنود يفقدون اطرافهم ويعانون
اصابات في العين والوجه وان معظم الاصابات
التي لحقت بجنود الجيش الاسرائيلي في غزه
ناتجه عن الاسلحه المتفجره مثل العبوات
الناسفه والقذائف الصاروخيه التي تسبب
المزيد من
الضرر قال تقرير في موقع بوليتيكو ان
تقديرات البنتاغون لتكلفه اعاده بناء
الوجود الامريكي في الشرق الاوسط بعد هجوم
السابع من اكتوبر على اسرائيل ستصل الى
اكثر من مليار دولار ونقل التقرير عن
مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم ان الولايات
المتحده لم تكن مستعده للتداعيات
الاقليميه لذلك الهجوم وان المشاهده داخل
البيت الابيض والبنتاغون ووزاره الخارجيه
ووكالات المخابرات في الاسابيع التي تلت
الهجوم تشبه الايام التي اعقبت الهجوم على
السفاره الامريكيه في بنغازي عام
2012 ختاما قال الكاتب سايمون تسدل في
صحيفه الجارديان ان الانتقام العسكريه
الامريكيه المباشره من ايران سيكون كارثه
على الشرق الاوسط ومن شانه ان يطيل امد
الصراع في غزه واضاف ان اي انتقام سيقسم
الديمقراطيات الغربيه ويساعد الصين في
تعزيز طموحاتها
[موسيقى]
الجيوسياسيه